What SAY You!
This program puts the spotlight
on voice actors
who are active in various fields.
We'll delve deep into their views
on their job and lives,
which you can't usually see,
in this documentary.
Hello, everyone.
I'm voice actor Yuki Kaji.
Looking forward to it.
I'm blushing.
I don't really…
Well, the viewers of anime, fans…
The chances of meeting them
would be at anime events or stage plays.
It's still difficult
to go to places like that.
There are difficulties to overcome.
So I want a chance or a place
to share entertainment.
I hope we'll get them back.
So it's places like theaters or movie theaters.
I hope we can go to those places soon
without worry.
I hope life gets back to normal.
You reserved a movie theater?
What amazing power.
And I'm going there?
Wow, I'd be happy to.
-Let's go now.
-May I?
Thank you. I'm looking forward to it.
This is impressive!
It's a real movie theater!
It's a luxury to be in this space.
When there are stage greeting events…
Of course, I often come to theaters
as an audience member too.
It's a bit lonely, empty like this!
Wow, this is the premium seat,
and the screen is very overwhelming
from this angle.
Excuse me.
Well, this is a luxury.
I think everyone gets excited
when movies are about to start.
I'm really feeling the anticipation.
I'm so excited.
Well, there are many movies
I'd like to see.
Needless to say, the ones I've acted in.
But the movies that blew me away
as a child, and that I still love,
are the Back to the Future films.
As a voice actor, I'd like to
play the characters.
They're characters that make me wish that.
I'd be moved if I could watch
those movies in the theater.
Is it possible?
It'll be so nice to watch them
in this great space.
I'm so happy.
Amazing!
I've lost count how of many times
I've watched this at home.
I was in third or fourth grade.
For the first time, other kids and I
bought our own tickets
and went to watch a movie on our own.
At that time,
Studio Ghibli's Princess Mononoke
was playing.
And…
I watched it for the first time
on a big screen, in the front row.
It was so powerful,
and my neck was tilting upwards like this.
Talk about fear.
Actually, there was some great timing.
During the COVID-19 pandemic,
we need to take necessary precautions
when we watch a movie in the theater.
And as part of the plan
to get more people to watch movies,
there was a revival of Ghibli movies.
When I looked up whether any movie
would fit my schedule,
Princess Mononoke was showing
at a time when I could go and watch.
Watching Princess Mononoke in a theater…
It was the movie I'd seen
only with other children alone,
so watching it again like that
was a rare experience.
And although in this year, 2020,
the situation became like this,
in terms of movies and theaters,
it was a great memory.
I was often the leader of the pack.
I was the kind of child
who often played that kind of role.
Apart from that,
as a child, I loved having dreams.
I was a strange child
who liked working hard toward my dreams.
Honestly, my dreams changed very often,
but I wanted to give it my all
when I did what I should do at the time.
Then I started middle school.
That was when I learned about a job
called "voice actor."
I don't remember
whether it was on TV or in a magazine,
I've even forgotten who said it,
but a very experienced voice actor said,
"Voice acting is a job
where everything you work hard for
will become your strength."
After hearing that,
because I always worked hard
to become a pro
in what I was facing
and aiming to achieve,
I felt that those words affirmed
what I did was right.
Since hearing those words and
working toward becoming a voice actor,
the dreams I'd changed
as often as every two or three days
turned into the dream
of becoming a voice actor alone.
I then started high school
and entered training school,
and I'm still doing this job now.
So I think it really was
a fateful encounter.
Well, it was incredible.
That alone makes me realize
I was given a great opportunity.
Somehow, this is sad, but...
I'm 35 now, but somehow…
Five years ago, when I was 30 years old,
I finally realized
what kind of person I was.
Fellow actors I'm friends with
told me what I was like,
so I found out what I was like
and how people saw me.
I finally realized that
I'm more annoying than I thought I was.
I'm a real pain in the neck
when it comes to various things.
I'm sure that as long as I'm an actor,
I'm bound to have some peculiarities.
Being annoying in a certain way
is a kind of weapon, something that…
makes you interesting.
I think it's okay to have that.
That's how I see myself.
A famous fortune teller like him
read my fortune? Can I watch it?
Thank you, Mr. Hoshi. I'll take a look.
I'm Hoshi.
Let's get started.
Please.
I'm nervous.
First, I'll look at Mr. Kaji's general luck.
My first impression of his palm is that
he's a very nice person.
-However…
-Wait, "however"?
he's not just nice.
His hidden strength
is shown on his left hand.
There is a long, straight line here.
It shows his ego.
Something like his ego and belief.
Perhaps what he shows people around him
is the gentle side,
but he has a backbone, a strong ego
and a strong sense of responsibility.
I can say he is hard-working.
This is one side of him.
When I read Mr. Kaji's fortune,
I see his professional luck is strong.
And this gradually spreads out,
so probably various kinds of work…
Maybe he will be offered work
besides voice acting.
Please try your best.
It's close to what we were talking about earlier.
It matches what other people told me
and how I think about myself.
Palm reading is amazing!
And I'm happy that
he said I had good professional luck
and I'd be offered new jobs.
If given various opportunities,
I would like to try some new things.
I really appreciate
his fortune telling.
Next, we are honored
to have the presence of our guest,
voice actor Mr. Yuki Kaji,
who will give us a speech.
Hello, I am Yuki Kaji.
Congratulations
on the opening of EJ Anime Hotel.
The scope of work as a voice actor,
the variety of the content of our work,
is gradually broadening.
It's become that kind of era.
Personally, as a voice actor
who acts with his voice,
I want to see how much I can grow
and use the experience I gained
to get feedback
and make myself useful as a voice actor.
That's what I think.
In fact, I have been asked to
attend events overseas.
The local people's passion about anime
and about voice actors,
I've had opportunities
to experience those things myself.
Times are hard in the middle
of the COVID-19 pandemic.
It has become quite difficult
to have such opportunities,
but this is exactly when it's important
to communicate with people
of various countries through anime.
When everything gets back to normal
someday,
I hope people overseas
will come to visit Japan,
and I'd like to go to countries
all over the world
to help and tell the people there
about the charm of anime.
I'm fine. Thank you.
Here I am.
Let's go to the studio over there.
Yes, I often come here
to do recording for video games.
Hello.
I'm usually in the booth
so I don't normally come to this room.
I'm nervous. Thanks for having me.
When people watch anime or dubbed movies,
they feel at peace,
or they gain the energy for tomorrow.
When I see reactions like that,
I feel glad this is my job.
The nephew of the makeup artist
who does makeup for me
watches The Seven Deadly Sins.
His dream for the future
is to become Meliodas,
a character I play.
When I heard he'd said that,
it reminded me of watching Dragon Ball
as a child
and wanting to become Goku.
So, in a different way,
this time, as a voice actor,
I'm the one
who can deliver hopes and dreams,
and I'm very glad to be a part of it.
When I had vague anxiety about
whether I could continue
doing this job or not…
a senior said to me,
"You'll be okay. I'm sure of it."
He kept telling me that.
That word, "okay"…
Of course the relationship between
who says it and hears it
plays a big part,
but I think that word is very powerful.
Even without any explanation,
if this person says I'll be okay,
then maybe I'll be okay.
I think that word gave me courage
and reassured me.
When my juniors are worried,
I say the same thing.
Of course, I hope I can actually
give them advice on techniques.
But I think the word "okay"
is very powerful,
so I want to tell them that.
Oh Mr. Kaji, it's Araki here.
Director!
-I've just talked a lot about you.
-Thank you.
-I think I said something nice.
-You're confident.
They were happy.
I think you're doing the recording
for the next season of Attack on Titan.
Regarding how you play Eren
in the final season,
it's become quite a hot topic
of discussion among us,
and I think the answer
you've been pondering for a long time
must be exploding now.
I'm looking forward to it.
I'll be asking you to join my work soon.
Please wait for that.
-See you.
-Bye.
Thank you.
Thank you, Director Araki.
I'm glad.
The character really opened up
a new field for me as an actor.
I couldn't be more grateful
for the opportunity to play him.
If the day I can work with Mr. Araki
on something comes again,
I will be very happy.
Not just work, either.
Let's go grab a drink soon.
Thank you, director.
First, he's very strict on himself
and very serious.
I think he also does
lots of preparation work.
He has as many as three, four jobs a day,
so he must take quite some time,
a day or two before, to prepare for them.
Anyway, he is ready when he goes to work.
He is ready and we can feel his pride
when he is standing there.
This has a good influence
on the other voice actors at the studio.
He only has to speak, and we all know
his presence is overwhelming.
On Attack on Titan, this is natural
because he's the protagonist,
but even when he isn't,
Mr. Kaji is still the leader.
We feel that this person
is the leader.
That's how the atmosphere is.
I don't mean he's intimidating.
It's the difference in talent
among other living creatures.
He only has to be there and we know.
I feel that no matter where he goes,
he becomes the leader there.
He is a serious person in nature.
A very serious person.
Okay.
Anime, video games,
stage plays, narration…
The scope of work for voice actors
is now expanding…
Well, I have nothing but dreams.
I'm still immature,
and there are many things
I'm not able to do yet.
Of course, I want to do more and more
new performances and characters
and play them wholeheartedly.
That's all I want.
Ever since I was little,
my dream has been to give my voice
to the heroes of live action dramas.
Like the movie I watched
at the theater today.
My dream is that when people
think about a certain actor,
and his voice in dubbed movies,
they'll think of me.
I hope someday I will have the chance
to be related to an actor like that.
Also, I want to do each of the jobs
I'm given with sincerity.
I'm grateful for the work I'm offered,
and I feel it strongly
after having experienced
the struggles of my early days.
I'll never forget to be grateful
and will keep trying various new things.
Thank you for having me.
Wow, I've spoken a lot.
I can't wait to see
what the program is like too.
Everyone, did you enjoy it?
I'll continue to do my best
as a voice actor.
Please cheer me on. Thank you.